Patrice lumumba's tooth was all that
remained after Belgian mercenaries
dissolved his body in a barrel of acid
he was assassinated with their
involvement in 1962 months after Congo
had been granted independence from
Belgian colonial rule
millions of people were killed and
mutilated over the 80 years that Belgium
extracted fast natural resource wealth
lumumba campaigned for Independence
now his tooth has been laid to rest in a
ceremony in Democratic Republic of
Congo's Capital Kinshasa
you died with your head held high your
faith unshakable and your confidence
deep in the destiny of your country more
than 60 years later I finally answer you
to tell you that you have returned home
the honors you receive here are a page
in the history that you continue to
write
the members remains have been interred
under his statue
their return is the latest in a series
of gestures from Belgium and its royal
family expressing regret for its
Colonial past that have followed the
rise of the black lives matter movement
Congolese president Felix chiseketti has
welcomed it
we Congolese and belgians can together
begin the decisive stage of forgiveness
Justice and true and definitive
reconciliation
remember was and still is wildly popular
his remains have drawn crowds as they've
been taken around the country over the
last nine days some say it only starts
to make up for the injustices of the
past
returning the truth is one step yes but
those who were involved in this
assassination are still alive there were
a list of 12
people belgians who were identified by
the Belgian Parliament as having Taken
part in this assassination two of those
people are still alive
people celebrated when lumumba's tooth
which was pulled out of his mouth by a
Belgian mercenary as a trophy was taken
to the place where he was killed
nobody's been held to account for it
returning lumumba's remains is a highly
symbolic gesture the Looting of Congo's
minerals conflict and poverty have
persisted far beyond independence from
Colonial rule
for many lumumba's vision of a free and
prosperous people is still a long way
off Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera